joining us right now is uh somebody who
uh i've been following since
you know i started with the nfl network
in 2003 uh he is now part of the
paparazzi for years now with fox sports
he was kind enough to run in my charity
run for uh saint jude earlier this year
and he's come up with a launching the
dual threat system training uh program
uh michael vick here on the rich eisen
show once again how are you michael vick
here on the mercedes-benz vans phone
line what's up michael
what's up rich how are you doing i'm
doing great i'm doing great uh i'm where
have i found you where where are you
i'm in i'm in south florida richard
still recovering from that
now it was charity based and i enjoyed
every moment of it but man rich i i mean
i laid it all out on the line you did it
you laid it all out of nowhere michael
you ran a 4-7 you're gonna be kidding me
you know what i mean hey rich but if i'm
telling i'm saying it on your show if if
i'm ever invited back you are on train
i'm gonna give it three months of
training i'm gonna make sean pull my
hamstrings so i can give everybody a
valid score well that
that
you know that time that i posted that's
not my time at 41. shouldn't have been
my time at 40. well 40. here's the deal
michael um
it the combine has now been announced
again last year there was no combine
because of the pandemic the combine's
been announced for indianapolis in late
march so uh we're beginning to start
planning for it i i think we might run
it there um if if we do you might have
to you know uh lay off the turkey leg a
little bit this week you know what i'm
saying
yeah that won't happen
give me
what is your thanksgiving looking like
michael where are you going to be well i
i i got family coming inside of me for a
lot of i got family coming in town
my mom my sisters my brother i haven't
seen
my family in in a while they they're all
in virginia uh i'm from i'm a florida
native now
um so you know it's good to have family
in town and we haven't spent things
given together in the last you know
maybe five or six years because of
everybody's traveling movement so very
thankful time and i'm looking forward to
it michael vick here uh on the rich
eisen show so let's get right into it
michael if you outlay you know your your
reputation and your ex expertise on one
team
in the nfc to go to the super bowl in
this who knows what year which one would
you choose
right now michael
right now um i i really i really like
dallas
and i i say that because
you know when i look at their offense i
i think that is peaking right now i
think he's playing at a high level and i
think once kelly moore looks back at
this kansas city cheese game and lost
he'll realize that i need to utilize
zeke more somehow some way so that
should make him a better play call in
the run game and i can see mike mccarthy
assistant in that
and in the receivers once they get a
mark cooper back you know 20 million
dollar bandits to be on the field you
know whatever protocol needs to happen
needs to happen and you know i like the
compliment with cd lamb so you know the
defense they missing some pieces and
some guys out
but once they get those guys back i
think you know they can make a super
bowl run and i didn't discredit any
other teams if i had this specifically
coin entertainment what i like a lot
about them is the dallas cowboys and
what they put on display well and you
know they they have shown uh with the
exception of i think last week
um they're they've been able to overcome
any problems on their depth chart
um
you know that would normally take a team
down they've had a pass rush despite not
having tank lawrence and now randy
gregory and it looks like they're going
to get both back and that one game dak
was out cooper rush was fine but you
know tyron smith can come back and that
that might make them a a winner on
thanksgiving that might be enough but
what about the cardinals let's just
throw that one out there man because uh
colt mccoy won two division games on the
road without kyler murray and deandre
hopkins they're gonna be the one seed
coming out of thanksgiving weekend no
matter what happens on sunday um so what
do you think about their chances michael
what about that team the cardinals i
think they do everything right it was
great to see cole mccoy be able to step
in when kylo went down injuries are
going to happen and guys got to step up
and usually when that happens the entire
team is uplifted because you lose your
leader and you know
i got to do my job today we got to help
colt he hasn't gotten all the reps he's
a guy that we know he's capable but you
know we need to do our job and and make
his job easier whether on defense is
getting in the ball back or offense you
know just playing smart football um so
with kyle in the lineup and when he
comes back this thing is dangerous i
said on the fox takeoff show a couple
weeks ago
that i thought
the
arizona cardinals was the best team in
the league
at five and one um so you know i still
think that's the case you know a lot of
moving parts got to get some guys
healthy but
you know as of right now arizona looks
good
so what do you think um what do you
think is ailing the bills michael i
don't know how you know deep you might
be into the all 22 but
i don't know what's going on you know
the saints are banged up i don't know if
that we're going to be able to get an
answer to it
i think buffalo should win this
thanksgiving night game coming up on nbc
but what what is going on because that
team suddenly is now in second place
and we were talking about that team
being the team to beat in the afc right
around september going into october and
now we're at thanksgiving and
i don't even know i don't even know if
they're going to be playing a home
playoff game this year
that's correct
uh and i think they lost to the
tennessee titans that night took a lot
out of
the buffalo bills it was you know one of
those deflating losses where you like
you give it everything you got and then
in the end it don't go right
and it's almost like an overtime
loss or it's almost like an overtime tie
where you just felt like you put so much
into the game you got nothing out of it
i think that game kind of set them back
mentally and and from a confidence
standpoint because from there it just
hasn't been consistent and i think josh
allen got to pick this team up and
collectively they got to look at what
they haven't been doing right
and uh and and try to right those wrongs
who wins that division when it's all
said and done do you think the bills
pull it out or are new england's going
to win it because of the way they're
looking what do you think honestly
rich i've been
a big fan of the new england patriots
this year and
you know i kind of gravitated towards
them because i picked them as my fantasy
defense in this fantasy league never
played fantasy before but you know now
i'm somehow involved in fantasy okay and
so i found myself rooting for them every
week but while i'm watching them i'm
seeing mac mac jones and matcha
just coming around
kind of learning how to play the game
learning how to win and it's been fun to
watch um so i think the buff i think the
buffalo bills are in trouble they got
two games versus new england if i'm not
mistaken
and those are going to be the the two
key games in
in in that division and obviously with
which can
two games that can shape the afc playoff
picture and i i don't think teams are
going to want to see new england because
they're getting better each and every
week who else is on your fantasy team
who's on michael vick's fantasy team
jonathan taylor oh i had an amazing week
last week yes you did with the patriots
defense too
with the patriots defense and jonathan
taylor i pretty much whipped the guy
single-handedly um so it was a good week
it was a good weekend fantasy and i you
know i got other guys you know russell
didn't help me out as much as the
quarterback position and
you know i
who you know i got some other guys you
know who produced um
yeah but you know that's that's a story
for another day rich i'm winning i'm
winning over there okay so russell
wilson is your fantasy michael vick's
fantasy quarterback is russell wilson
yes he is and jonathan taylor is my
running back
running back so uh
serious actual football question here
michael vick did the falcons make a
mistake drafting kyle pitts and not
taking a quarterback or trading back and
trying to help themselves out
roster-wise
is it fair to have that conversation
here right now
i do think
kyle pitts is a was a good pick for the
falcons and
i do think that atlanta was thinking
about you know the future of matt ryan
you know seriously but
you know you look at a guy like matt you
can see that he still has some years
left and maybe want to want to build
around him but i did
think that it was it was an opportunity
to draft one of these young guys maybe
you could have got max zones and you
could have set back behind matt and
you know that wouldn't have you know
been beneficial for new england but you
know for atlanta in the long term
you know it would have i think it would
have paid dividends or you know any of
those guys
um but you know you got a great guy that
you can learn from behind a great
quarterback and
and my ryan that you can learn from and
gain some experience and knowledge and
you know so yeah we kind of missed the
ball right there but um no good thing is
a draft next year if that's what they
think they need to do but i like cal and
i you know remind me of plexico bears if
they can use them right and you know
being paired with the right quarterback
how to get the most out of it lexico
burroughs a tight end that's kind of
frightening so um
if you had justin field's ear right now
what would you tell him michael
if i had justin fields here if you had
if you had an ability to talk to justin
fields what advice would you give him
right now so you know i spoke to justin
and
you know i just told him this is a
learning opportunity you know this is
year one and
expectations are high yes people want to
see promise and then that's fair it's
only fair to the bass fans the fan base
and i think he gets that and but year
two is gonna be the year that you gotta
you gotta grow
and you have to put all your skills in
display and people are gonna wanna see
you know what justin fields is really
all about so i try to help them
understand the game from that
perspective like you do get a trial run
in here right yeah one you do have some
guys who
you know the mac jones of the world who
you can step into you know the line of
fire and get it done but you got to have
the right supporting cast and
you know that's not the case then
in chicago right now so
you know once they
fix everything around justin fields and
try to you know help him then you know
definitely won't be any excuses but
he understand what's at stake he knows
his position and what you know and how
he has to produce what about the scheme
that's around him what you're seeing for
him what about that this is the coaching
staff yeah what is that this game is not
beneficial right now because we haven't
seen the production and you know as a
coach you know and matt miggy and matt
and i we know each other well and
you know we'll probably have the same
conversation you know it's a lot of
things that can go wrong on the offense
and why things won't go right but you
know i think
you know maybe you you run out of
sometimes you run out of time and you
don't have a chance to
um you know getting do-overs so you know
they got to clean it up quickly you know
i think tomorrow's game against detroit
they have to win
and that's a must win game and they got
to go on a win streak so we'll see what
happens but they were supposed to win
last week and that that didn't help that
is good winning that game versus
baltimore didn't help well i mean look
at that
the kid from utah
comes out of nowhere lamar jackson sends
him a text as lamar is coming on the bus
saying i'm watching today i can't make
it you got to go right i mean and then
that kid that kid makes the throw of the
game and and wins right you know right
and and and like he does that and
everybody's watching and it's like
why can't we get that you know from
either our quarterbacks
so that's kind of just you know the
state of the franchise before i let you
go tell me about this uh the system that
you this dual threat um plan that you
have put together
michael because yeah you know
what are you thinking about me this is
this is my lane it's the opportunity to
teach is the opportunity to enlighten
kids
do a lot of football camps and
um
you know i teach a lot of kids the game
of football but i only get a split
second with them you know in that day
you know it's just a small fraction of
time so
you know i figure i put out the dual
threat system still get a lot of kids
who ask me you know whether i'm out you
know at home depot or whether i'm just
out hanging out with my family you know
how can i be a dual threat quarterback
what do i need to do and you know hey
got a great opportunity with this
company
um pro class to put it out and
you know to be all types of
demonstrations from now into the end of
time you know just building speed and
how to you know chase perfection at the
quarterback position so you know you can
go to www.proclass.com
backslash vic
and uh you know you get a lot of
education and teaching and we'll
continue to grow
you know as we continue to build content
so what would my second threat be i
already know what my first thought would
be through the system training what is
the dual threat what would it be talking
and running is that what it believed
like that that would be nice
hey why you you either got to be passing
or you got to be running ready one of
the two move the chains
no talking in between okay
but that's my game though talking is my
game that's my problem
you know all right we we teach verbiage
too because what offense you went okay
uh what what offense am i in i don't
know spread i don't know you like a
running shoe guys
that's right i don't need a tight
[Music]
yeah that's right i need glanville on my
ear that's exactly what i need no that's
the last guy you need
very motivated take care of yourself
michael vick have a great thanksgiving
with your family we'll do this again
soon all right you do the same thing
that's michael vick the one and only
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here